we've been following the situation with
donald trump's former personal attorney
rudy giuliani
whose home in office were raided by the
fbi last week
now while some claimed that this was
clearly
the work of joe biden the real reason
that it took this long
for rudy to get raided is that trump
appointees to the justice department
blocked the warrants while donald trump
was still
president so rudy gave an interview to
tucker carlson last week it was a
complete disaster
rudy tried again this week to exonerate
himself
on the sean hannity program and it
didn't go any better and in fact
in fact it raised new questions about
rudy giuliani's possible wrongdoing this
is
a very common trend we see on the right
accused of something or suspected of
something they do
some kind of public facing event to
claim innocence and
it raises more questions about all of
the things they may be guilty of so
let's jump right into the first clip
rudy assuring us that he is definitely
absolutely completely not a russian
agent
my reaction is the headline of the
washington post giuliani
briefed on russian connection they've
been trying to make me a russian agent
for about three years
which is totally nuts i'm probably the
biggest anti-communist he ever met
uh there's no way that i'm a russian
agent or anybody else's agent
i was a lawyer who was representing a
client who was innocent
the biggest burden a lawyer can have is
to represent an innocent man
and i did it damn well and and i have
exposed
that our president is one of the biggest
criminals in the history of the country
thank you a real hero that rudy giuliani
and definitely not a russian agent okay
then rudy continues by alleging that
this entire investigation into him which
remember
started during trump's administration
and has nothing to do with joe biden
is all concocted to destroy his
credibility
and this is i mean this is totally
done because they want to
destroy my credibility because i have
that entire hard drive
i have the whole thing i put it out to
the
imagine being the guy who flew around
the country making bogus election claims
who thought that melissa carone would be
a star witness in michigan
who loudly farted relentlessly just bomb
after bomb through a hearing in whatever
state
that took place in got covered likely
spread covered
and you think they need this to
discredit you it is just
out of this world delusional and then to
end the interview
rudy coming back after all this trouble
with his bogus election claims claiming
he has all the evidence
and it's on it's on podcast episodes one
through eight if you can believe it
persecuted because i brought it out i
have it and you're saying that there is
more illegal activity that we haven't
heard about i want to i want to ask a
quick last question you're saying that
there is other stuff we will learn
likely in the future that yes if you if
if
yes sir if you would like to if you
would like to get a preview
go to my early podcast one through eight
where i put the evidence out i'll give
you an example
there is a clear money laundering
violation
involving the biden family it's on paper
from
uh from ukraine to latvia to cyprus
to a hidden bank account last question i
would only
i would keep you on longer if i had to
the time that's right
he's being investigated for his
involvement with the ukraine fiasco
for his lobbying activities while
serving as the
personal attorney to a sitting president
of the united states but
none of that is the real story the real
story is the
hunter biden cypriot money
money laundering story which you can
learn about in rudy's podcast episodes
one through eight
during which he also advertises cigars
can you
imagine so if you were unsure
whether rudy seemed guilty before this
interview
i don't think this interview helps at
all i come away from this interview
thinking wow there's even
more things that we should be
investigating
when it comes to rudy giuliani not
enough attention is being made to all of
the ways in which rudy giuliani may be
guilty of wrongdoing
i don't even know for whose benefit rudy
is doing these interviews at this point
certainly they aren't helping his actual
legal case
if he's trying to try this in the court
of public opinion
i don't think it's helping that either
so my question to you
what is the point of all this why is
rudy doing these interviews and what
exactly is he trying to achieve
let me know what you think and we'll
follow up about it later this week
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information
so this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman